speaking of coercive liberalism this
story is really spooky
this is a daily wire exclusive Vanguard
is I think it's the largest provider of
mutual funds in the world second largest
provider of ETFs after BlackRock which
also has gone just as woke as Vanguard
Vanguard just had a training that they
subjected their employees to Vanguard
has seven trillion dollars of assets
under management when Vanguard says they
want something the company's under
management generally do it
and Vanguard had a diversity equity and
inclusion training to get all of the
white men associated with Vanguard and
the companies that it invests in
to get on board with the woke philosophy
This research research I'm about to
present to
inclusion depending on how you look at
it in terms of us really ensuring and
partnering with some of the leading
companies in the field to ensure that
white men white male managers are
actively included in the Dei
conversation and that's the piece of
research and that's the critical lever
that we're here to talk about today
engaging white male managers and
advancing diversity and inclusion we
partnered with as I mentioned some of
the four most thinkers in the Dei field
and are so thrilled at Vanguard for
being one of our leading sponsors I'm
going to translate that from all that
woke gibberish that you just heard when
she says they need the white men in the
middle management they need to be
actively
included to get on board what that means
is that the companies need to force the
white guys into a re-education Camp
presumably one being led by this woman
she says the white men need to be held
accountable
education set for Dei prioritization
engagement and adult parts
there's Clarity on how both senior
leaders and middle managers will and
should be held accountable
that we reinforce accountability through
Performance Management process and
feedback channels sort of added
commentary here I would say just like we
do for business results that are so
important right
we need accountability through the
feedback channels and just like we have
for their actual productivity we're
going to do that for this woke ideology
the translation is fire the white guys
if they don't pledge fealty to this new
woke racial hierarchy that people like
this crazy lady are pushing and then
finally finally you have the insistence
by Vanguard that white men be held to
uncomfortable criticism
do be aware
look no I'm sorry
did you learn how to listen and accept
criticism with grace even if it's
uncomfortable a growth mindset principle
in many ways is if you're going it's
likely uncomfortable this isn't supposed
to be easy it's supposed to be hard this
isn't supposed to be easy it's supposed
to be hard especially to those white men
that translation here is the white guys
are going to be held to a different
harsher standard and we're all supposed
to go along with this okay this is being
pushed not by the government even this
is being pushed by what we what we call
the regime The Blob The Establishment
the power structure is being pushed by a
company with seven trillion dollars in
assets under management when they say
they want something like this they get
it from their companies this is what
conservatives have to push back against
and if all conservatives can offer is
what the same kind of platitudes they've
offered for the last 20 years which is
just get the governor and out of my life
just as less government then we're not
going to do anything because the power
that's really being wielded in our
society is being wielded largely outside
of the government
by the propagandists in the media by the
insane ideologues in Corporate America
by all by the lunatics in Academia
that's where it's being wielded
some people get it that we've got to
fight them on those grounds we've got to
that's what DeSantis is doing with the
education bill in Florida that you see a
tax on what corporate on what
corporations for that matter too that's
going to be the way of the future if we
do not lean into that we will not
conserve a damn thing I'm glad you like
that clip now you know we hit a million
subscribers I'm so pleased I'm really
thrilled about the million subscribers I
get the nice gold play button it's very
very cool you've got to head on over
though and ring this Bell and get the
notifications and subscribe because I
want to hit a billion subscribers so do
it now thank you see you next time
[Music]
[Music]